calling in from Kansas City calling the
Chiefs and chargers the tnf finale the
first season of Thursday Night Football
on Fox finale here is Joe Buck how are
you Joseph I'm well rich how are you and
all of your friends in the studio do you
want to answer that question yourselves
guys I'm good Joe I'm a little tired I
could use some my stop I get tired I'm
all about tired this is good by the way
Chris you're complaining about your
fatigue too a guy went from LCS to
Thursday night to LCS to World Series to
Thursday night to World Series
okay and I don't have twins if you don't
have twins at home yeah yeah all right
John sorry I'm not tired anymore
okay good I just I'm here to I'm here to
wake you up there you golf Joe Buck
personal caffeine for Chris Brockman
here on the Rich Eisen show all right
tonight's game Joe what do you want to
hit let's let's hit the fantasy first so
many people want to know about Tyreke l
Melvin Gordon what do you think going
into this game from what you've gleaned
through each team about tonight's
readiness yeah I think I think what I
read is what we learned when we talked
to the two head coaches and and got
their honest opinion at least I'd like
to think it's an honest opinion as Andy
Reid has been steadfast and saying it's
no issue with Tyreke l that's what he
told us on the phone yesterday
and I would expect him to go as I sit
here in the hotel room and I look
outside the window it is a damp chilly
day not cold it could be a way worse but
it is damp and I think that might slow
down the plans for Gordon I don't know
that this is the game thinking about
where they sit already in the AFC
playoff picture that that you want to
put your guy that's got you know however
severe the terror is that's what a
sprained knee is it's a small tear and
and run him out on this field and see
how he plays why who knows but a they
were hoping it wouldn't be damp and it's
damp and it is that
so okay we'll see what happens obviously
when active inactive reports go down
ninety minutes before you you hit air
with Troy and I mean when you look at it
I guess that the Chargers would need to
obviously win this and then get another
chief loss combined with the Chargers
winning out essentially in order to win
the division and get that by week so I
guess there is still a longer game to be
played for the Chargers here with Melvin
Gordon when you think of it I I think so
you know this when we asked Anthony Lynn
or I did you know I said is this one of
those games where you empty the bucket
or is this one where you go okay yeah
it'd be great to win it but let's be
realistic about where we are about where
they are meaning Kansas City and Kansas
City is in a great spot mainly because
of the season they've had but also
because of that loss that crazy loss at
Miami by New England
last Sunday so I don't know I mean it's
it's a hell of a matchup it's a great
game it's eleven and two against ten and
three but both are pretty solid where
they are right now in the overall
playoff picture and I don't know that
it's realistic for it to change before
the end of the season so I think they're
gonna they're gonna try to win the
ballgame but I think as you said there's
a longer game to be played really for
each side and I'm going through my my
head right now to see just to think if
you've had the Chiefs yet on Sunday
because this is their first Thursday
night games is this your first look at
my homes this year Joe oh god yeah I
mean this is this is our first Kansas
City game in in I don't know four years
no kidding five years somewhere in there
and then Troy and I were trying to think
the last time we had the Chargers they
were obviously in San Diego and I think
it was a preseason game in 2014 so it's
been a long time for for each side I
think Phillip Rivers has had like 17
kids this was last
well so many maybe even more than you
over the last you know he was talking
let me look at we just turned 37 the
other day right
he's got me beat his wife is pregnant
with their ninth child and that is
unbeliev
they're by bit and they have the same
split as far as kids over nine children
seven girls two boys for the third
straight generation in that family I do
not know how he does it I honestly don't
I don't either and they still live in
basically the San Diego area I know
Peter King did a piece on him a couple
weeks ago talking about this conversion
van and he watches film to and from
their practice facility headed north so
I it's just his schedules got to be just
you talk about tired I know he wins well
I mean it's working for him I mean he's
not he's never really plated as high a
level like this with the weapons that
he's had really I mean when you when you
think of the Chargers in the
conversation about them this year Joe
when Melvin Gordon is healthy they're at
the top of the most complete team list
when you are thinking about the 2018
season you know I agree and it's I think
hey you're right about Phillip Rivers
has been great and B I think their
defense might be better than the other
ones involved in the conversation so no
doubt but it is pretty remarkable that
Phillip Rivers at 37 is putting together
the the season that he's putting
together being in his 15th year and
obviously that same draft class with Eli
and Big Ben and you know they're their
records speak for themselves but I think
when you look at the body of work for
Phillip Rivers the only thing missing is
getting to and then winning a Super Bowl
compared to the other two guys but as
far as you know physical health and
ability and slinging it around and
finding different guys and he's he's I
don't know you could make the argument
that of those three right now in 2018
he's the guy you'd want is one last
question on this game before we move on
to the rest of the NFL here Joseph
you're the perfect person ask this since
you haven't had a Chiefs game in quite
some time did you have you found Andy
Reed if
obviously you were you sat down with him
and a lot of these pre broadcast
meetings or had him on the phone for
years in Philadelphia he appears to be
just playing a coaching like he's got
house money these days Jojo right we
talked to him and that was my question
kind of going out I said you know
because of our travel schedule we used
to sit down with a lot of these head
coaches and these players now we do a
ton of of our research in our little
meetings on the phone and players like
that better of course and and so two
head coaches to just pick up the phone
instead of coming into a meeting but I
feel like we were with Andy Reed every
other week when he was in Philadelphia
and just talking to him on the phone he
was like a different person he was and I
said it to him I said you sound
energized you sound you know like you're
having way more fun he sound like you're
willing to give a ton more information
by the end of his time in Philadelphia
and I think for good reason he was just
kind of he was burnt and and I think he
was he was tired of talking about the
failings of not getting over the hump he
took them to a Super Bowl as you know as
well as I and couldn't win in that Oh
fourth season but I think it just
drained him and him being in Kansas City
and now him hitting the lottery with
mahomes he gets a lot of credit you know
to trade up get him at the number 10
pick and then trade Alex Smith who led
the league in quarterback rating who
took this team to the playoffs year
after year they were division champion
back-to-back seasons and to go okay we
saw enough in a week 17 start with
mahomes two to trade Alex Smith and go
with the kid and for this kid to beat
this good dad that's it that's a major
win for Andy Reid and I don't know that
he gets enough credit around the league
for that Joe Buck calling in from Kansas
City prior to calling Chiefs Chargers
tonight on the Thursday Night Football
finale and we want to talk about a team
that with within the season that you've
seen change I mean you called the
Cowboys season opening loss that
Carolina I think you were in Seattle if
I'm not mistaken with Troy yeah in week
3 when Seattle beat
Dallas in that game and you called the
game against the Saints Thursday night
football game totally different team
right I mean I must imagine you being
around that team in weeks one and three
and and obviously now completely
different and and believing they can
take everybody out right now correct
yeah I think so and and the defense is
the first thing that comes to mind when
you think of the Dallas Cowboys and what
they did a couple of weeks ago or at
least a couple of games ago against New
Orleans I don't think anybody saw that
coming we knew they were good I don't
know that we had seen that level of good
by the Dallas Cowboys or anybody for
that matter against the New Orleans
Saints but I dak Prescott the same guy
as they were as he was earlier in the
year
obviously Amari Cooper has added a ton
it's given them a lot of confidence
offensively it's given them somebody
that the defense clearly has to account
for I don't know that he's in the
category of AJ Green when he's healthy
DeAndre Hopkins I mean that level but
but when you talk to the football people
they will tell you that Amari Cooper's
route running is second to none and so
you have to give him a little more
attention but they're still stacked up
to stop Ezekiel Elliott
I think the offensive line has gotten a
lot better it's gelled I think they're
over the hump with not having Travis
Frederick they've played all year it
feels like with Zack Martin being banged
up and now he's banged up again but I
think they're a little more equipped to
handle it I think a lot of things have
happened it's not just a Maury Cooper
the offensive line is better and the
defense is just sensational there's
their secondaries awesome yeah I know I
don't know that that people talked about
it well it's kind of lost amongst the
Bears certainly over what they did the
last week against the Rams but they're
that yeah we had Jaylon Smith on the
show a couple days ago he is beyond
impressive I mean what a dream come true
to put on the field every day obviously
and and then send out into the community
all the time and tonight's the finale of
Thursday Night Football
Joe and I mean it's been an incredible
season from Baker Mayfield coming in in
week three
- - last week were you aware when
Derrick Henry scored that 99 yarder that
your dad had called Tony Dorsett just
like you had just called Derrick Henry
was that were you aware of that right
away no in fact I mean yeah I knew he
had called it but when I'm doing the
game I'm kind of in my little bubble
there and at some point about 10 minutes
after it happened in real time not game
time our producer Richie giants mm-hmm
excuse me got in my ear and said do you
know of the many things that you have in
common with your dad you just added
another one and even that clue didn't
make any synapses fire and have me come
up with the answer that we'd both called
in 99-yard run and he told me and and it
was cool it was neat to share that and
then I think I've tweeted something I
know I tweeted something that a buddy of
Mines producer mashed up between the two
calls and to have that connection to
have there there only being two in the
history of the league and for him to
call it on a Monday night in 1983 and me
to call it on a Thursday night last week
it was really cool I that that kind of
hit me listening to it it made me choke
up yeah he's about to ask you that I
mean because I choked up I couldn't I'm
like wow that is stuff you can't make up
Joe that's amazing it really really yeah
but I cry at the voice didn't like
America's come on now so I you know I I
when I heard him and it was funny
because at one point Dorsett was going
down the right sideline and Henry was
going down the left sideline and I so he
kind of law you lose perspective when
you're when he's away on the other far
sideline and I thought he had stepped
out of bounds or might have and at one
point my dad says you know Tony door
said he might go or whatever he says
he's at 30 25 he steps out of bounds no
he didn't step out of bounds and then he
scores the touchdown and I was so close
to saying that same thing that's but I
just stopped I hesitated just enough to
see that the referee or the official was
down there letting it go and so I just
shut up and let him get in
the end zone before it's just a great
call Joe it's just a great moment and a
great poll by your by the whole
production it's been a great season it
really really really has so before I let
you go we want to help here because you
did say the other day that the words in
the hunt as part of the playoff picture
that's used by everybody I don't even
know if there's somebody in the NFL
office who has mandated the words in the
hunt be used for teams it's amazing to
be the New York Times I read it you know
USA Today is on every Network you guys
used it yes everywhere so we came up
with I think I texted you during the
game on the scent you could drop that
tonight yeah
or sniffing it just come on you know
just come up just come out and basically
say hey later on we were this is about
the AFC wild card or the AFC West but
later on this week and the Dolphins are
in Minnesota
dolphins are sniffing it Colts are
sniffing it what do you think yeah no I
yeah I don't know my mind kind of raises
with that one no the three million
filters that are in those are firing
right now this I'm trying to get your
juices flowing well well before kickoff
right here I just I'm gonna pin down
Aikman broadcast and say hey look
without Carson Wentz or the Eagles still
sniffing it that's it there you go
that works right there Andrew Luck
against the Cowboys Andrew Luck's Colts
are sniffing it again you know after
losing Miami yeah you're right that's
another good sniffing a team I yeah I'm
not opposed to it I'm just saying that
in this world you know with with
everybody on alert
I don't know that sniffing it is
something that I should probably throw
out all right well just you know we'll
workshop it maybe I'll text you if we
come up with a better one before kickoff
but on the scent or sniffing it if you
give me a better one I will for sure our
graphic will not say in the hunt it will
say whatever you give me okay I like it
all right we've got an hour plus left
here a lot of pressure it's a wake up
okay all right just giving us a homework
assignment
thanks again Joe appreciate it all right
take care yeah you bet that's judge oppa
that buck on Twitter here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience